in this lesson you're going to learn how
to graph quadratic equations these are
the parabola shape graphs and what we're
going to do is we're going to work
through all these different forms of the
quadratic equation here to graph these
parabolas in these different forms so
we've got the vertex form the intercept
form the standard form and then some of
the parent function graphs we're also
going to talk about transformations and
we're going to talk about how to
approach these graphs so you can easily
get a good graph so let's dive in the
first problem is just to basically look
at the y equals x squared form of the
equation and this is what we call our
parent function what you can do is you
can just pick some points I usually pick
a couple negative zero and a couple
positive and we're just going to put
those in for X so we've got negative 3
squared which is 9 negative 2 squared
which is 4 negative 1 squared which is 1
0 squared is 0 1 squared is 1 times 1
which is 1 2 squared is 2 times 2 which
is 4 and 3 squared is 9 now let's go
ahead and plot these points and we've
got negative 3 9 which is way up here so
I'm going to skip that one negative 2 4
which is right here negative 1 1 which
is here 0 0 1 1 2 4 3 9 but when you
graph this you get this nice like
u-shaped graph ok and that's what we
call a parabola now what happens when
you have like for number two we have y
equals two x squared what do you think
that 2 does to the graph well see this
this is the form we're working with now
the a value if it's greater than 1 it
stretches the graph and if it's between
0 & 1 it shrinks the graph okay it's a
vertical shrink like a compression and
if it's negative what it does is it
reflects it over the x axis it's going
to make it open down okay and we're
gonna look at all those different types
now so let's go ahead and look at y
equals 2x squared again you can make a
table sometimes what students make a
mistake is they think about working from
left to right you want to think of doing
the order of operations the PEMDAS so if
we put negative 2 in here and we square
it negative 2 squared is negative 2
times negative 2 which is 4 times this 2
here which gives us 8 negative 1 squared
is 1 times 2 is 2 0 squared of 0
times two is 0 1 squared is 1 times 2 is
2 and 2 squared is 4 times 2 is 8 now
one thing that you probably notice is
that see how these values here are the
same these values here are the same and
that's because the graph is symmetric
about this axis of symmetry now when we
talk about axis of symmetry it's this
vertical line okay that divides the
parabola in half and this parent
function that line is the line x equals
0 remember x equals lines are vertical
lines whereas y equals lines are the
horizontal lines the other thing I want
to talk about and this is something that
sometimes when I'm working with students
tutoring students you know their
teachers give them all different like
little techniques and you might find
this helpful when this a value is
positive you can think about it when
you're positive what do you do you smile
right so you can think of a is positive
that opens up see that smile there we go
whereas if you think about being
negative right say if the a value is
negative opening down see how this is
kind of like a frown okay opening down
so you could use that as a way of kind
of remembering if that helps you well
let's go ahead and plot these points I'm
going to switch colors here let's go to
green and we've got let's see negative
two eight which is way up here we've got
negative 1/2 which is right here 0 0
which is here 1 2 which is here and 2 8
which is way up here so when you look at
this graph what do you notice
well the two okay that a value is
greater than one so it's a vertical
stretch which means that the graph is
going up faster some people refer to
this as being narrower but I just like
to think of it as a vertical stretch
like you're pulling it up vertically and
that's why it's you know like narrower
like that the other thing that comes up
when you're doing these problems is
domain and range so when you think about
domain you think about what can the X
values be so I usually look from left to
right and we think about the range you
think about what can the Y values be so
I kind of think from low to high with
these parabolas that we're gonna be
working with in this video the domain is
always going to be all real numbers so
that means that X can go all the way to
negative infinity all the way to
positive infinity when we look at the
range
okay the y-values you can see why is not
negative over here it is equal to zero
it just touches right at the x-axis and
it's above the x-axis so we say that the
range is y is greater than or equal to
zero if you're using the interval
notation as you go on in math it's going
to be looking something like this where
it's equal to zero all the way up to
positive infinity can never reach
infinity that's an open interval here on
the right so we're gonna work with
inequalities though for this video so
let's go to number three now what do you
think happens here with y equals
one-half x squared well if you said that
the one-half is going to be a vertical
shrink you're absolutely right and
that's again it's because this a value
here is between zero and one so when
it's less than one like that but it's
still positive you know it's going to be
a vertical shrink we're going to talk
about negative next so let's go ahead
and plot some points here so we've got
negative two let's see negative two
squared is four times 1/2 is 2 negative
1 squared is 1 times 1/2 is 1/2 is 0
squared of 0 times 1/2 is 0 and then
these are going to be the same okay see
how it's symmetric it's the same on both
sides so let's plot that on the same
graph so we can see what this looks like
negative 2 to negative 1
1/2 0 0 1 1/2 and 2 2 so here you see
the red graph this is a vertical shrink
so what happened was it actually made
the graph wider see the black one was
the original one the red one is the new
one and it's just a vertical shrink or
compressing it making it wider the
domain and the range are exactly the
same so these are just when you're
talking about the a Val you're talking
about the vertical stretch or shrink or
and number 4 where you see that it's
negative a value then it's going to be a
reflection over the x-axis and it's
going to open downward just like we said
wouldn't this a value is negative it's
kind of like when a person's negative
they're frowning okay it's gonna be
opening downward so let's plot a few
values here we're gonna get into some
more difficult ones here in just a
minute but I just want to lay the
foundation here for you so you kind of
know you know how these all work just
working with the parent
so we've got negative 2 squared which is
4 now remember some people think
negative times a negative oh isn't that
a positive Mario well remember you want
to do the exponents first so negative 2
squared is 4 times a negative is going
to give us a negative 4 negative 1
squared is 1 times a negative gives us
negative 1 0 squared is 0 times a
negative is still 0 and then we're
getting the same negative 1 negative 4
so if we plot those negative 2 negative
4 negative 1 negative 1 0 0 1 negative 1
and 2 negative 4 what you'll notice is
that it has the same shape as the
original graph the y equals x squared
the parent function okay same shape it's
just been reflected over the x-axis ok
all right so let's dive into some of the
ones that involve ax squared plus c next
now what do you think that C value does
to the graph well let's take a look in
number five so I'm gonna make a table
I'm gonna pick like I did before just
some small numbers a couple negative and
a couple positive and let's take a look
so I put negative 2 in negative 2
squared is 4 plus 3 is 7 negative 1
squared is 1 plus 3 is 4 0 squared is 0
plus 3 is 3 1 squared is 1 plus 3 is 4
and 2 squared is 4 plus 3 is 7 let's go
ahead and plot these we've got negative
2 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 right about there
negative 1/4 right about there 0 3 1 4
into 7 so there's our graph and notice
this 3 see how it crosses the y-axis
right at 3 so what this did dead here
the 3 the C value picked up the graph
and it moved it up 3 so that's what we
call a translation or a slide or a shift
usually translations that's probably a
more proper term is shifting up 3 units
now if you look at this y equals x
squared that's our basic parent function
that we talked about in the very first
problem we just picked it up and move it
up 3 so that's for number 5 number 6 now
what do you think happens here y equals
x squared minus 2 we are probably saying
Mario I see that y equals x squared
again but that minus 2 is going to show
down to right so what you can do is you
can make a table again but if you're
starting to catch on to the pattern here
you can say well I know this it just
shifts down to why don't I just pretend
like negative two here is my new origin
my new starting point then I could make
a table just using my parent function y
equals x squared and plot from here so
let's go ahead and do that so this would
be negative 2 4 negative 1 a 1 0 0 1 1
and 2 4 it's just I'm gonna plot these
points from here now so I'm going left 2
up 4 left 1 up 1 0 0 right 1 up 1 and
right chew up for now you don't have to
do it this way if you don't feel
comfortable you can use the whole
equation but just remember when you use
the whole equation you want to plot from
the 0 0 point that origin if you just
use the y equals ax squared part of the
equation then you can graph from that
shifted origin okay up or down okay
let's look at number 7 now we're putting
together this a value 3 with the C value
1 so what do you think happens here in
this problem well the 3 is going to be a
vertical stretch and we know that when
it's a stretch like that it's gonna make
the graph look narrower because it's
going up faster right but the plus 1 is
going to shift it up 1 ok so again you
can use the whole equation if you want
or you can do the little shortcut that I
was showing you could just use the y
equals 3x squared and plot from here up
1 either way you're gonna get the same
graph so I'm going to use the whole
equation this time so I'm just going to
put a negative 2 negative 1 0 1 & 2
remember the order of operation is
negative 2 squared is 4 times 3 is 12
plus 1 is 13 negative 1 is negative 1
squared is 1 times 3 is 3 plus 1 is 4 0
is going to give you 0 squared times 3
is 0 plus 1 is 1 and then it's going to
be the same on the other side because
it's symmetric about this axis of
symmetry now sometimes what you can do
when you draw this you can draw it as
kind of like a dashed or dotted line
that axis of symmetry so far all the
problems we've worked with that axis of
symmetry is x equals 0 right on the y
axis there if you fold it over that line
it's going to
to itself that graph is gonna pair up
like that so now let's go ahead and
graph this so we've got negative 213
that's way off the graph negative 1/4
which is right here 0 1 1 4 2 13 now
you're probably saying what Mario why is
it going way off the graph like that
well because remember the 3 is
stretching it right so it's the further
you out it's going to go up really fast
right now the one thing we haven't
talked about yet is the maximum and the
minimum so what does that mean maximum
and minimum well when they a value is
positive remember positive smiling it's
opening up like this you actually have a
minimum a low point but you don't have a
maximum see how it keeps going up to
infinity forever and ever so when it
opens up its positive you have a minimum
and what is the minimum value meaning
what is the lowest that this graph goes
to well the lowest is going to be the
y-coordinate here okay of this point
which is going to be y equals 1 so in
here in this case the minimum is y
equals 1 or you could just say 1 this
point where the graph bends ok we
haven't talked about this yet is the
vertex ok so this point where it's
changing direction it's going to be the
low point or the high point with these
parabolas we call our vertex ok number 8
and number 9 we're going to be working
with this standard form y equals ax
squared plus BX plus C okay of a
quadratic and the question here now is
how do we figure out where that vertex
is and we're going to introduce a
formula here now x equals the opposite
of B or negative B divided by 2 times a
now remember when you graph these
parabolas remember how they always have
that symmetry and that that line is
symmetry divides the parabola on half if
you fold over that line it matches to
itself this axis to symmetry the formula
for that axis of symmetry will be x
equals negative B over 2a
and the negative B over 2a will also be
the x-coordinate of this vertex point
right here so let me show you how that
works with number 8 notice that the a
value here is 1 because 1 x squared is
the same as x squared so a equals 1 B is
equal to 2 C positive 2 and C is equal
to 3 so what we're going to do is we're
going to do let's write it up here a
B and C so we have x equals the opposite
of b over 2a so the opposite of B is
going to be negative 2 over 2 times 1 so
negative 2 over 2 comes out to negative
1 that's the x-coordinate of our vertex
it's also the line of symmetry right
here x equals negative 1 now how do we
find the y coordinate of the vertex well
we have to take this negative 1 put it
back in for X and that'll give us our Y
values so let's go ahead and do that we
have y equals 1 times negative 1 squared
plus 2 times negative 1 plus 3 so this
comes out to 1 minus 2 plus 3 which
that's 4 minus 2 which is 2 so negative
1 2 is our vertex let's plot that on the
graph right here and now what students
like to do to get a good graph is
somebody's I'll make a table like this
okay kind of like a horizontal fashion
like this and what they like to do is
put the vertex in the middle so you see
our vertex is negative 1 2 and then what
we're going to do is we're going to pick
some points on either side okay of this
axis of symmetry like negative 2
negative 3 0 1 so all I'm doing is I'm
adding 1 subtracting 1 or adding 2
subtracting 2 and the idea is it's going
to be the same on both sides of this
line so if I put 0 in 0 squared is 0
times 1 is 0 plus 2 times 0 is 0 so
these all came out to 0 plus 3 more
that's 3 but then I also know that this
one on the other side is also 3 if I put
1 in 1 squared is 1 times 1 is 1 plus 2
times 1 is 2 plus 1 is 3 plus 3 is 6
this one here will also be 6 it's the
same on both sides so let's go ahead and
plot that we've got I let's see negative
3 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 and we've got negative 1
2 let's see I got that and negative 2 3
which is right there and 0 3 & 1 6 so
there we go we've got our graph this
graph has a minimum the minimum value is
2 let's see what else we have in the
domain is all real numbers
the range what can y be well Y can be
two or greater so we would say our range
is y is greater than or equal to two
domain is all real numbers we said and
that's it so you've got a good graph so
now let's jump over to number nine same
idea we have y equals ax squared plus BX
plus C okay but we need to find that
vertex using our formula negative B over
2a notice the a value is negative what
does that tell us the parabolas going to
open down like that okay so let's go
ahead and do this we've got this is a
here B here and C here now make sure you
capture that sign to the left or in
front so we have the opposite of
negative 8 which is positive 8 divided
by 2 times a which is 2 times negative 2
so this becomes 8 over negative 4 which
is negative 2 so negative 2 that's the
x-coordinate of our vertex is also the x
equals negative 2 is our axis of
symmetry and if we want to find the y
coordinate of the vertex we have to take
that negative 2 and put it back in now
be careful when you put it back in you
do your order of operations so negative
2 times negative 2 squared minus 8 times
negative 2 plus 1 so that's going to be
4 times negative 2 is negative 8 these
two negatives give us positive 16 so we
get 8 plus 1 which is 9 so our vertex is
going to be let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
right there
okay V for vertex and now I'm going to
show you another method here you can do
this table method okay but what you can
also do is once you find that vertex you
can focus in on the parent function that
y equals ax squared that gives us the
basic shape of the graph how wide it is
or how narrow it is and whether it opens
up or opens down so I'm just going to
make a table on this part right here
let's do it over here and let's pick
just a couple of easy values negative 2
negative 1 0 1 2 and this comes out to
negative 8 negative 2 0 negative 2 and
negative 8 and now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna plot from this point I'm gonna
pretend like this is our origin I'm
gonna go left to down 8 ok so let's see
that would be right about
here and then the thing is you can then
reflect it over this line of symmetry so
see how I'm two units away if I go two
units on the other side of the axis of
symmetry have another point and negative
one negative two so from here I'm going
left one down two and say I'm one unit
away if I go one unit on the other side
I have another point and now we have our
graph now another key point you want to
pay attention to is when you're working
with either this form or this form see
the C value the C value is the
y-intercept that's where it crosses the
y axis so see how this is one see how
it's crossing right here at one so it's
an easy point to locate and then once
you know that point you can then reflect
it over the line of symmetry to get
another point usually you want to have 3
points ideally five points to get a nice
smooth graph now this graph has a
maximum right because it's opening down
it has a high point it's like top of the
hill here and what is the maximum well
it's going to be the y coordinate of the
vertex is going to be 9 the range is
going to be y is less than or equal to 9
see it's 9 or below and the domain
because this graph gradually goes to the
left and right forever and ever the
domain is again all real numbers okay
number 10 and number 11 we're going to
talk about the vertex form now that's
this y equals a times the quantity X
minus H squared plus K and the vertex at
point where the graph bends you know the
maximum or the minimum point that vertex
point is going to be at H comma K now
where students sometimes get a little
bit confused is see how this is X minus
H so we want to pay attention to his
this number here this in the parentheses
with the ax that number it's that H
value is going to be the opposite from
this sign so see this looks like it's a
negative 1 it's actually going to be the
Ox s can be positive 1 it's actually X
minus and then each is actually positive
1 so that's our vertex 1 and then the K
value this is going to be the same sign
so see this is minus 2 or negative 2
it's going to be negative 2 so just
remember this one is the opposite and
this one here is the same as the sign
some students that I tutor their teacher
will say well this one lies and this one
tells the truth and I
find that kind of humorous but if it
helps you remember that's always good so
let's see so the vertex here is right
one down two okay so that's your vertex
and then here's your line of symmetry
right that divides the parabola in half
if you fold it over that line it matched
it to itself and now you have a lot of
different options one option is you
could say well let me just pick some
points on either side of this point okay
or let me look at the parent function y
equals one-half x squared see I'm
basically looking at this y equals ax
squared form and graph from here as if
it's the origin a lot of different
options I'm just gonna make a table I
think this is a student's most favorite
method put the vertex in the middle and
then pick some points on either side so
I'm gonna cook 0 and negative one and
two and three so all I'm doing is adding
one or subtracting one adding to or
subtracting two so it's basically it's
the same on both sides so let's put zero
and zero is usually easy to work with 0
minus 1 is negative 1 negative 1 squared
is positive 1 times 1/2 is 1/2 minus 2
is negative 1 and 1/2 so that means this
one over here is also negative 1 and 1/2
and if we put in let's say 3 now 3 minus
1 is 2 2 squared is 4 times 1/2 is 2
minus 2 is 0 so that means this one over
here will also be 0 it's the same on
both sides so now we can graph we've got
0 negative 1 and 1/2 which is right here
and I fold it over that line of symmetry
see it's gonna be right there which is
the same as 2 and then comma negative 1
and 1/2 and then we have 3 0 and again I
can reflect it over that line a symmetry
or negative 1 0 right here and one thing
you'll be noticing about this graph is
that because of the 1/2 it's a little
bit wider right it's just opening up
quieter and what else we know that it's
opening up because the a value is
positive this has a minimum value that
minimum value is going to be at negative
2 the axis of symmetry is going to be
right here through the x-coordinate of
the vertex
x equals 1 and the range is going to be
y is greater than or equal to negative 2
and we covered it right so also got
number 11 a little bit different here
see if you can do this one on your own
the vertex what do you think the vertex
is of this quadratic well remember this
one we said it lies right or it's the
opposite right the plus two is actually
gonna shift left to and the plus one is
the same so it's gonna go positive one
up one so there's our vertex right there
at negative to positive one here's our
axis of symmetry I just like to draw it
as a dashed or dotted line it's you
won't really see that when you graph the
parabola we're just using it as a guide
our axis of symmetry is x equals
negative two same as x coordinate the
vertex the e value is negative that
tells us that Bradwell is gonna be
opening down right negative like
frowning right and the four is gonna
stretch it so that means it's gonna be
very narrow but now what we can do is we
can use the same table method I think
again like I said this is probably
students favorite way of doing it put
that vertex in the middle negative two
one and let's pick some points on either
side so negative 3 negative 4 negative 1
and 0 so if we put in let's see negative
1 that would be pretty easy let's see
negative 1 plus 2 is 1 1 squared is 1
times negative 4 is negative 4 plus 1 is
negative 3
so that means this one here is also
negative 3 right they're the same if we
put 0 + 0 is easy to work with 0 plus 2
is 2 2 squared is 4 - 4 times negative 4
is negative 16 plus 1 is negative 15
that means this one over here is also
negative 15
these ones are probably going to go away
off the graph so let's just do these
ones in the middle we've got negative 3
negative 3 which is right here and then
we have negative 1 negative 3 which is
right here so you can see it's opening
down it's narrow and you've got a pretty
good sketch to the graph number 12 and
number 13 we're gonna be working with
what's called the intercept form of the
equation of a quadratic ok a parabola
and the idea here is with the intercept
form is the when it's in this form this
factored form what we can easily
identify are the x-intercepts or what
are often referred to as the zeros
whereas over here in the vertex form one
can easily identify the vertex in this
form here we can I easily identify the
y-intercept right there because we have
the
values the y-intercept so each form has
kind of like its pauses and it's
negatives right but for this one we can
see it's in the factored form and the
way we find those zeros remember the
zeros means where the y-value is equal
to zero when y is zero that means we're
right along the x axis because we're not
going up or down and that gives us those
x-intercepts so what we do is we set y
equal to zero and what you do is you set
these factors or these groups equal to
zero so you can make a mini equation X
minus 1 equals 0 and X minus 3 equals 0
add 1 to both sides add 3 to both sides
and you can see that our zeros or our
x-intercepts are going to be at 1 & 3
now what we can do from here once we
find these x-intercepts
is we can add them together and divide
by 2 so 1 plus 3 is 4 divided by 2 is 2
now what is that to do for us well it
gives us the axis of symmetry
okay so x equals 2 and because the
vertex lies along that axis of symmetry
we know the x-coordinate of the vertex
is going to be 2 all we have to do now
is put the tube back and for X to find
our y coordinate of our vertex and we
got it so let's do that 2 minus 1 is 1
and 2 minus 3 is negative 1 and so we
have 2 times 1 is 2 times negative 1 is
negative 2 and so now we've got our
vertex here at 2 negative 2 one thing to
notice is that see how this a value is
positive that tells us the graph is
opening up if this was negative then it
would be opening down now what I want to
show you here is we were doing the
negative B over 2a that was for the
standard form but here what we're doing
is we're doing P plus Q divided by 2 so
P and Q these are our x-intercepts if
you add those together and divide by 2
that's going to give you the x
coordinate of the vertex and also the
axis of symmetry so now I've got a
pretty good graph if you want to plot
some more points you can instead of
plotting like we did 1 2 & 3 we could do
like 0 that would give you your
y-intercept or it could 4 you can pick
some other points to get more on your
graph for number 13 now notice that this
a value is negative or negative 1 so we
know it's going to open
if we set each of these factors equal to
zero we're going to get X minus three
equals zero so x equals three and X plus
three equals zero so x equals negative
three so this is where it's going to be
crossing the x-axis here at three and
negative three and if we use our P plus
Q over two formula just like an average
you're adding them together and dividing
by two that comes out to three plus
negative three is zero divided by two is
zero okay so this is our axis of
symmetry right here on the y axis x
equals zero if we put zero back in we
get negative zero minus three times zero
plus three which is negative nine times
a negative is positive nine so this is
going to be zero comma nine one two
three four five six seven eight nine and
now we have a pretty good sketch of our
parabola it's opening down because it is
negative we've got our vertex here which
was the average of the two x-intercepts
this is a maximum and the maximum value
is nine and we know the axis of symmetry
x equals zero we know that the range is
going to be below this maximum so y is
less than or equal to nine the domain is
all real numbers and you got it so in
the comments put down your favorite
method for graphing these quadratics are
these parabolas and if you want to see
more examples follow me over to that
video right there where I'll dive into
some more examples I'll see you in the
next video